we got some exciting flow facts coming
your way folks okay
meteorologist ted florento puts a lot of
time into these i really do yeah does it
have something to do with the clouds
outside that's it nice right now
for
this is incredible i wanted to show you
this flow factor our normal amount of
rain by now guys should be over two
inches of rain should be by now so far
we've only had sixteen hundredths of an
inch babysitting is it babysitting baby
sex
that baby needs to be a toddler now
a baby needs to jump up to you know what
it's time to grow up
babysit it's time to grow up all right
we need the rain
rain totals and i wanted to show you
this because there's nothing measurable
in las vegas yeah we picked up a trays
but remember that storm i pinpointed on
t over mountain pass a quarter of an
inch there in less than half an hour
that's how much rain came down sixteen
hundredths of an inch this is good
springs there right now we're tracking
more of that rate of the south now like
we talked about a lot of it doesn't hold
together dies out and that's what we've
been seeing with this latest one there
are some showers now over uh near blue
diamond over sr 160 and we're also
seeing some rainfall down here coming
down this is the 15 right now southern
highlands you're located right here this
right here st rose parkway probably
getting some showers here for you right
now in these areas here there are
neighborhoods there so we're keeping our
eye on this as we zoom out there's still
more activity here down your state line
passing state line coming up from the
south so some of this has the potential
to bring us some rain for our
neighborhoods the southwest first so
we're keeping our eye on that we hope so
we need it we need it currently outside
85 for summerlin 87 for downtown
temperatures have cooled off 95 for
green valley 89 for southern highlands
if we get that rain to pass through some
of the
more moderate rain to even light rain to
pass through temperatures will drop so
we're hoping we'll get some 80 and
prompt 103 for laughton right now
your futurecast does show slight chance
of still around for early evening not so
much late night tonight but tomorrow
once we get that daytime heating kicking
again i think there'll be clear skies so
that'll allow these things to cook up
more cells could pop up for tomorrow in
the afternoon so we're not ruling out
the possibility of more storms tomorrow
humidity's gone up now that we've had
some rain come through that's allowed
the dew points to go up that will give
us more
more of a chance for some isolated
thunderstorms hit miss thunderstorms
around the region look at eight o'clock
tomorrow night could see some even east
county before friday we start to dry out
our main impacts with these storms that
we're going to be seeing tonight and
tomorrow of course first winds very
gusty winds and then we could see some
lightning along with that along with
some rain that we've seen already the
risk of widespread flooding seems pretty
low with these right now tonight 77
degrees clearing overnight isolated
showers and storms still a possibility
at least early evening 100 tomorrow
chance of hit-and-miss storms gusty
outflow winds it's going to be hot and
humid too because remember the humidity
is up and it's going to stay that way
tomorrow here is your 8 day forecast
those chances tomorrow not so much this
weekend we heat it up we dry out next
week there are slight chances but right
now it's going to call for mostly sunny
skies and temperatures stay
hot and above average
that's your weather update kirsten